si l'avenir
quoi quoi quoi quoi c'est débile vous
devez répondre en imitant bourvil non
c'est pas terrible du tout je vais
rebondir
ce couvercle en bref un bon je sais pas
faire bourvil monsieur mais j'ai fait
comme tout le monde la ddc
mon vélo derrière l eau h 2
alors pour moi plan rendiez mon vélo de
mon vélo
bon non c'est pas tout ça à prévoir de
faire la promo de palais des congrès la
renie bas c'est vrai que je me suis
embarqué dans un plan auquel je
m'attendais pas c'est à dire aller
baryton en deux mois
fait plus de six cent mille albums du
liban cet album là déjà 600 mille six
cent soixante mille et un buteur qui
s'appelle baryton un dogme est vraiment
super bon finalement allons au bout du
délire et on n'a qu'à faire le spectacle
mais on va pas faire un concert pagny on
va faire spectacle baryton on va prendre
le grand orchestre philharmonique et
puis voilà
et puis là ça y est ces journalistes
150000 quand même si tu peux
bizouard la banque continue chez les
bruits de la croix parle de donner 5
mais ceux là sont déjà payés ah bon bah
ouais mais c'est une dame solide avance
il est fort un panier abad à partie
devant toi mon pote donc combien de
musiciens sur scène français âgé de
soixante c'est cher les musiciens
surtout endurcir bas c'est pour ça que
tu vois je sais pas à quoi il allait
m'attendre et voilà soixante dix chefs
d'orchestre comme ça yvan cassar la 1re
cassard qui me fait le plaisir d'être là
patricia petibon qui vient m'aider
soixante musiciens le palais des congrès
bon voilà on y va on va sacrifier aux
blacks bravo
une journée avec ce spectacle et après
septembre octobre novembre sur la route
ouais avec les 60 musiciens mais en plus
en plus des 60 musiciens il est vrai
qu'à un moment ces fusions en variété
pop avec classique je peux pas non plus
faire que orchestre et je viens chanter
le répertoire faut je propose aussi un
spectacle qui va avec et aujourd'hui
c'est des projections des light enfin il
ya forcément tout un truc qui va donc ça
devient du bien cher ça de la
superproduction avec un plaisir de le
faire
musicien par jour c'est combien
écoute je sais pas je croise des
sandales 320 50 euros 50 euros sur la
tournée je crois qu'ils à 110 euros par
jour un truc comme cela qu'elle ne
tourne et la tiennent ils tant mieux
tomber arriver